how's the Gomer as my spirit path
welcome to dread out if you remember we
played this a year ago I think it was a
demo and it was a really really good
demo
it's an Indonesian horror game and
apparently I have a lot of fans from
Indonesia so that's kind of cool but the
game looks great it's finally out it's a
horror game in case you haven't figured
that out yet I don't know what else to
say about it I'm just excited to check
out what it's all about it I think I'm
in the game also which is pretty cool
I supported the Kickstarter and they
wanted to do Slee Ramudu like eggs you
know but your thingy oh god that is
creepy old women are the worst okay
great dream what the hell are they doing
without your smile cuz I know I love
that's awesome picture
I expect that [ __ ] are you sure we're
going the right way man hmm I think so
but how did the road suddenly get so bad
just like the road by our school the
hell does that mean Jesus poor guy
what what is it now Oh sad old lady
something bad happens let's get out of
the car okay
ah what is that it looks like some place
you don't want to go I guess we're going
there slap that ass no I can't all right
I love I I'm not sure a lot of people
will yeah where are we miss this guy I
really wasn't expecting there to be a
bridge here that complicates things a
bit hey miss Siska are you listening
stop ignoring me senpai notice me so
technically you shouldn't be too far
from home hmm is this exactly what now
yeah well now surely miss Cisco what we
should have done was taken a left turn
initially turned round to counter
section and then went straight before
turning around and making a left instead
of a right know-it-all blabbermouth
excuse me guys oh my sass
please just calm down okay oh he is this
place is so awesome
not really oh man cool so how do we get
over there there's gotta be a way
somewhere
all right it's game reminds me a fatal
frame a little bit it reminds me of like
a new PlayStation 2 horror game which is
pretty good I really like that feel hey
that'll we got a picture um okay well
you can leave look into the camera come
on come on give me that face oh there
you go I smile for me baby Oh work it
BFF achievement I love this game already
alright what is it um nothing
am i boring you Jesus goddamn what a
wreck with a bridge - sighs this is a
disaster well this is just great huh
it's kind of like a horror movie isn't
it oh you know the first one to die is
usually a perky girl just like you Sally
better be careful
yeah yeah that is so not funny
I died I'm totally going to haunt you I
bet that's gonna happen as long as the
ghost looks like you I won't be
complaining if in your dreams pervert I
like how in other countries they have
school uniforms what are we supposed to
do now and we'd like the tiniest class
ever come on dad pick up why don't you
just pick up the phone I like that so
far hold on a sec
I have to take a [ __ ] okay oh yeah what
is he doing listen road here is me hello
Oh fantastic
over here all this [ __ ] you find a bush
oh god this is not gonna end well it's
cool creepy right it reminds me of so
many things but so many things that I
like said I like in you you know well
that shows them leadership then Jesus oh
god he's really running off isn't he
holy [ __ ] ha ha hello there bro hello I
see my ass is no I did not say that I
say have frosting my jazz men
it's my jasmine rice
Selam I buy bang be my favorite place in
the whole world oh my God we're so lucky
well this is incredibly odd what cuz if
the names deliberately smudged off ah
yeah
I'll paint my purpose hmm it's very odd
thumbnail size super creepy look I'm
already getting goose bumps why do we
have to go in here anyway
can't we just go home already there's no
way a natural disaster caused this a lot
of the buildings are still intact see
uh-huh
well then we're gonna have to find out
what happened dan don't we dare what do
we do with you it's time for scooby-doo
in the game except we're not god damn it
I am on your right knee and scooby-doo
okay okay what's the what I'm pop yeah
really don't understand this teacher
though I just feel like no we're going
back oh [ __ ] what don't do that
objective updated what could that be
also my beautiful pictures like sighs
fantastic okay what to do this town has
been decided for a long time maybe the
bridge that connects to the main road
has collapsed it seemed like everyone is
that really interested in checking it
ouch
cool how long are we gonna check this
out like just leave the car there I want
to do that well I guess we can take a
lot of selfies on other people like all
OH
Alfie's I try right again very good
it's a gas station yep no swirly things
underneath the cars not on my watch
get in man wait what are these giant
things so this is what Indonesia looks
like great place love to visit I'm
joking
oh yeah that's Skrillex square legs what
are you doing here oh yeah it is how can
it just be a bat abandoned schools not
on my radar main what are you what are
you doing don't don't don't use that
face I don't like that face man
selfie your nostrils is sticking out you
know
oh Jesus she scared me oh he scared me I
haven't seen him in forever and he shows
up now don't freak us out like that okay
well now what we're all here the gag is
here skipper Doo and the gang and to GU
why am I the only one with a school bag
you guys don't even care about school
dude bunch of bad words yep
all right well I'm going into school
then is you guys are way too [ __ ]
slow
doesn't that see look exactly like the
one we used to hang out on in elementary
school that's not there for a bit
looks like a pretty generic [ __ ] seat
reminds me of the first time we met
why that money don't remember don't you
oh no typical girl time
hey guys we're about to check out the
inside
want to come ones later okay your loss
why did she slap me hey we got an
[ __ ]
you two stay here okay where hey going
now
I so need a massage yeah I remember the
weather was cloudy I'm just like this
our ride never showed up we clicked
right away didn't we why looked right
away didn't we
you're such an a-hole remember when we
used to be in Girl Scouts together no
who was that one teacher he disguised
himself as a pop song oh the potes ha ha
ha freaked out but you weren't even
fazed and you threw a rock at him no it
was more like the size of a boulder I
love the animation you know is kind of
like my personal bodyguard
though right says hey I have it called
Eustace in a long time what the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] talking about I don't know oh don't
know what's happening I don't Oh what
hold on
they've been in there for a really long
time we should probably go check on them
I don't like that I don't like that one
bit
oh god now the creepy stuff begins this
is what the game is really all about
this is what I remember from the demo
cuz it's really [ __ ] creepy oh my god
it's so dark I really don't see [ __ ]
[ __ ] bang okay I did see [ __ ] and got a
mad Beijing and getting so Derek not
[ __ ] what happened
it's like some kind of crazy museum tour
or something what the it's already dark
out how long long anyway it really is
getting late okay kids gather round it's
time to head back uh uh maybe he'll an
insane yacht ah crap where the heck did
he run off to now
mutt yawn why so creepy love that name
yeah yawn oh god what is she doing I
call his phone and trying to right now
miss Sisca
I don't like what she's doing y'all yawn
I don't like it at one bit what Oh relax
is swelling
oh nice split bruh BAM this game is
amazing I love it
[ __ ] hisses creepy I don't like this oh
god okay I guess we're stuck at this
abandoned creepy ghost town school could
be worse I could be in JB's vagina why
did I say that
Thank You brain for picturing that okay
oh god was I did I see something or what
no I probably I was a singer and
treatment unlock get scared of bias
there okay we're like us we're going
upstairs was that a joke
millipedes Wow best youtuber ever oh god
I would just kill myself if I was in a
place like this or I'd become a mouse
that's probably what I would do because
no one no guns no ghost has ever haunted
a mouse you know I'm saying it's [ __ ]
genius okay oh god I'm gonna die Oh Jeff
lamb even vibrate it private number all
right I guess
great car great car favorite call best
phone caliber ten out of ten would phone
call again
oh god it's behind Mary's name oh what
the [ __ ] was that not pigs man oh yeah
blur what was that
okay
you know what I'm gonna have to end the
first episode there I don't know what to
say
let's pretty interesting at least and I
think it'll be pretty interesting you
what's gonna happen even next so leave
like for your watching breaths let me
know if you want more I'm gonna play
bore anyway cuz it's awesome but it's
this kind of common road today and I'll
see you tomorrow
love your us say awesome there's some
brothers point